Speaker 1: Folks, the right has a new meme.
I don't know if mass formations psychosis is
completely killing. Let's go, Brandon. But
it is spreading rapidly on the virus front.
We have Omicron rapidly out competing delta on
the mimetic front. Right wing memes a we quickly
have mass formation. Psychosis, overwhelming
let's go brand. And they can probably coexist.
What am I? What am I talking about? Mass
formation psychosis? Let me set this up for you.
There's this guy called the Robert Malone. Robert
Malone is someone who has for a period of time now
been credited with and taken credit for
developing MRK vaccine technology. Now
this is a claim that has been fact checked quite a
bit. It's a bit of an exaggeration. What the right
wingers want you to believe is that Robert Malone
is the guy who created M RNA vaccination, and now
he's totally against it and thinks it's terrible
and dangerous and wants to destroy the monster he
created and bring all these different stuff. OK?
A more sober analysis, and you can just Google.
A number of different, very good stories
about this is that he was one of many people
over a long period of time who did research that
contributed to the development of the technology,
which of course eventually can get
applied to one thing or another. And now
a couple of the current COVID vaccines are based
on the mirror. OK, you get the idea. Right? So so
that's part number one. The second part
is Robert Malone has now been banned from
Twitter for spreading COVID disinformation.
And this is, of course, bringing out all of the
that's fascism and communism and authoritarianism
and its violation of free speech and all these
different sorts bringing out those people.
It's also bringing out the people who are of
the mindset of the truth, trademark the truth
about COVID vaccines and COVID itself is being
suppressed, it's being covered up, et cetera, et
cetera. So Robert Malone got himself an appearance
on an emergency podcast with Joe Rogan, and in
it, he I don't know that he coined the term, but
he kind of made a portmanteau of two terms that
exist. And that term is mass formation psychosis.
He is saying that this mob's psychosis plagues
the side of science when it comes to COVID. And
what is incredible? I mean, this clip has gone
giga viral, millions upon millions of views.
When you listen to what he's saying, it sounds
like he's explaining what is plaguing the
American right wing, the COVID deniers,
the vaccine conspiracists, the Trumpers,
the stop, the Steelers, but he's not talking
about that. Let's just get right into the clip,
and then we're going to talk about it.
Speaker 2: Listen really closely from basically
European intellectual inquiry into what the heck
happened in Germany in the 20s and 30s, you know,
very intelligent, highly educated population, and
they went barking mad. And how did that happen?
The answer is mass formation psychosis.
When you have a society that has become
decoupled from each other and has free floating
anxiety in a sense that things don't make sense.
We can't understand it. And then
their attention gets focused by
a leader or series of events, guys.
Speaker 1: He's describing Trumpism.
What we have. I mean, it's do I almost feel
like I'm over it's it's too on the nose. Like,
I feel like if I give any explanation, I'm over
explaining. It sounds like he's describing the
mass psychosis of Trumpism that I've been talking
about for years, but he's not. He's talking
about people who accept the vaccine science
Speaker 2: on one small point, just like hypnosis.
They literally become hypnotized and
can be led anywhere. And yeah.
Speaker 1: And seventy something
million of them ended up voting for Trump.
Speaker 2: One of the aspects of that phenomena
is the people that they identify as their
leaders, the ones typically that come in
and say, You have this pain and I can
solve it for you. I and I alone, guys.
Speaker 1: He's quoting Trump. He he's
quoting Trump. Here is here. Is Trump
literally saying I alone can fix it.
Speaker 3: I alone can fix it. Or it will restore
law and order
Speaker 1: to our country.
Do you guys remember that it? He's quoting Trump
verbatim, but we're supposed to believe it's the,
you know, I don't want to call it the left
because there's Republicans that accept science
and piers it. I've never seen anything like this.
Speaker 2: OK, I can fix this problem for you.
OK, then they will lead. They will
follow that person through. It doesn't
matter whether they lie to him or whatever.
Speaker 1: That's exactly what happened with
Trump. He lied to them about
all of it. I mean, how does
it? They're all on this now. All the right wingers
now. Yeah. Robert Malone explain what's going on
with these leftists, this mass for me.
Speaker 2: The data are irrelevant. And
furthermore, anybody who questions that narrative
right is to be immediately attacked the other.
This is central to mass formation psychosis,
and this is what has happened. We had all
those conditions. If you remember back
before 2019, everybody was complaining. The
world doesn't make sense, blah blah blah.
And we're all isolated from each other.
We're all in our little tools. We're not connected
socially anymore, except through social media.
Speaker 1: There's something about these types of
tip. Typically, it's it's guys. Where they talk
in a certain way. I mean, where they do what
they're accusing when he talks about hypnosis,
what when you listen to the way that Bret
Weinstein has spoken about vaccines, he goes,
well, the it's spike protein is cytotoxic. And
I am concerned that they have a way of talking.
And Ben Shapiro has it, too, although it's a
different way, very different way of talking
where it almost doesn't matter what they say
now what now they're all talking about mass
formation, psychosis. What is that? There's a
combination. The term mass formation psychology
is a preexisting term, and it just means
like crowd or mob psychology. And they're
just saying he's adding psychosis to it to say,
Well, it's a form of psychosis. It's a mass,
it's a mob psychosis of sorts. What is incredible
about this is that we have to share this because
this is the best description I've
ever heard of the MAGA movement,
except he's not applying it to that.
When I listen to it, I'm thinking, Wow,
what a what a perfect analysis of what has plagued
this country with the MAGA movement for years now.
But he's not talking about that. Like the
the unaware lack of awareness about the irony
is incredible now. Just because you come up with
a name for something doesn't mean it accurately
describes anything. And the truth is, I've been
describing what's going on since COVID in this way
for a long time. You know, back in January
of last year 2021, I did a segment called the
shared psychosis of Trumpism. I mean, I literally
described this, except he's he's describing it,
but not actually talking about Trumpism. In May
of last year, I did a segment called 54 percent of
Republicans think Trump riots were led by violent
left wing protesters were. I described this
as a group psychosis. That's verbatim the
word that I used. So it's not a new concept,
and it couldn't be more of an instance of
projection, but this is their new meme.
Robert Malone is their new hero, and the new meme
is mass formation psychosis, and they lack the
ability or awareness to realize it applies to them
better than to anybody else. They might point the
finger at. Send me your thoughts. You can find me
on Twitter at Packman. Curious to hear from you?